sponsored by step finance your go to d5
portfolio manager on solana luna if
you're just getting into bitcoin it's
the perfect place to start
hey guys anna welcome back to another
episode of the lay higher plan show
today we are talking all things crypto
we're talking about the markets because
who really knows where we're at right
now maybe my guest will so as usual this
is powered by the vc firm icon plus
capital and it is also sponsored by
block fight if you're interested there
is a link in the description and in the
comments section you can get around 250
when you sign up and they offer amazing
interest rates
so let's kick things off joining me
today is rao powell he's the founder and
ceo of global macro investor and of real
vision let's bring rao on how you doing
ral i'm great how are you
i'm good thank you i'm good it's been a
while since we last chatted so
balance
so i lost you then you froze
can you hear me okay yeah i can now
okay perfect how are things going on
down in the cayman islands what do you
do all day there
me i'm just 14 hours of meetings all day
on zoom so i am crazy busy apart from
the weekends because every weekend is a
caribbean holiday
wow it sounds pretty amazing i've never
been i'd have to check it out one day
um
white sand beaches turquoise clear warm
water
it sounds like you're living the life
but ralph can we please get a portfol a
portfolio update before we go into this
i know you're constantly switching up
changing your holdings you know you're
bullish on different metaverse coins
nfts one moment you're all in on bitcoin
now i know
not now can we get a portfolio update i
actually don't change my portfolio often
at all so the only answer okay i did is
i started in 2020 all in on bitcoin then
i started shifting towards ethereum
then i bought a basket which included a
bunch of metaverse plays some social
tokens some um layer ones other stuff
and i basically kept that so i don't
think i've traded anything apart from
buying some nfts um and then
yeah i the only other major switch was i
got i sold most of my bitcoin for
ethereum um about six nine months ago
yeah okay so probably i'm probably still
85 percent each and then 15 other stuff
see even i think that is huge all that
youth but we'll get into it before we do
um i want to know your opinion on earth
happened at the end of last year we were
all sort of expecting this super cycle
um and we didn't quite get it
what happened
i think two things happened first
firstly price got ahead of network
activity so what happened was people
weren't
there weren't there wasn't
a lot of new transactions in the network
either value transacted
wasn't going up and the number of new
wallets or active wallets wasn't going
up so price went up and the network
didn't and it didn't stick
and the issue was
inflation
so why does inflation matter well
because the
cryptos still a retail network right
it's really driven by retail and if
you've raised prices on people and wages
don't go up as much they've got less
discretionary income that discretionary
income was the dollar cost averaging
that went into crypto and so people
stopped because they had to pay their
grocery bills or their rent
so that's why it just stopped so it
shows how macroeconomics influences
crypto markets in ways that people don't
quite yet understand but that was the
big that was the big thing that happened
end of last year and has continued to
weigh on the market this year because
network growth hasn't really improved so
we've seen rotations within the market
so we saw people switching from each to
layer ones and we saw nfts hold their
value you know stuff as people are
reallocating what they've got in the
market generally reallocating eth um you
know a lot of bitcoin people
you know tend to stick with bitcoin um
but a lot of the eth people reallocated
different parts of eth like you know
nfts particularly got a lot of attention
you make an interesting point about
inflation because a lot of people sort
of say oh you know inflation's up and so
the market's going to go because people
are going to be moving to bitcoin um
bitcoin's down today inflation
apparently is at new record highs today
eight and a half percent um in the us
so where do you think we're at with the
market right now
it's a bit of a confusing situation um
we can talk about cycles in a minute but
where specifically do you think we're at
with the market
the balance of probabilities is that
we made the low last year
we retested the low this year
and i think the low is in
but
who the hell really knows right so you
know i got the back end of last year
wrong like everybody else i thought you
know we were going to get this run and
and we didn't see it
i think
we've thrown
a war eight and a half percent inflation
the fed raising interest rates
all at crypto
um we've thrown chinese
ban we've thrown so much at it and it
didn't make a new low
kind of usually that's a signal the
market kind of
has found its its bottom
and so now we're looking for okay what
are the upside catalysts the upside
catalyst would be
if economic growth starts slowing
um we're likely to see then long
duration assets things that
um tend to outperform in low growth
environments and crypto tends to very
well in in that kind of environment much
like kathy woods arc does those kind of
you know longer term assets so that's
what we're looking for
um as the spark i think is a is a change
in structure so people fear inflation
less and stop fearing growth more
yeah and i think it's interesting to see
how you mention china there and the
market seems to be quite desensitized at
this point to all the fud that comes out
of china um you know which is incredibly
bullish for the the maturity of the
market but
a lot of a lot i've been watching a lot
of content online and people like willy
woo for example sort of say that this
idea of these four year cycles driven by
bitcoins halving is over
i personally don't know where i stand on
that so
where do you sound on that do you think
these four year cycles are over given
how much institutional
money we now have flowing into it
uh yeah i think it's over because
the market is much larger than it was
and bitcoin is not as dominant
so at the margin
the four year cycle will have an impact
but not as large an impact you know for
example the 2.0
thing is going to create a potential
dynamic that's different
so
um
i think i think the cycles have changed
and i think you know over time
these very volatile trends get less
volatile and we saw that with amazon in
its early days it was like up and down
95 percent then 65 percent and then just
gets less and less and less because more
people are in the network so it's the
same with crypto now you know there's
there's 600 million people 300 million
people using it now so what's happening
is the volatility dampened so you know
the i think the new down 85 percent is
the new down 50 is the down 50 where we
are now so it's kind of like we've had a
bear market we've been in a bear market
for a year you know could it go down 65
possibly but you know it's unlikely to
go down 85 percent people have a very
recency bias and they only unders they
only know what they know
and people who've been in the bitcoin
market have only been around you know a
network adoption model
for a decade so they've only seen a few
cycles but if you go to
facebook amazon google they've all had
these for decades and you can see how
they work and they tend to lower
volatility over time
so you don't think we'd necessarily have
to wait an entire four years with that
cold cold winter until we see a new
all-time high no no i don't
it's possible but i don't think it's the
most likely outcome now
i think you know we just need the macro
environment to shift a bit
um and we've got different players in
the market and it's a much deeper market
there now than it used to be
by the way i think there's a little bit
of a delay between your nights probably
on my end yeah it's on my end so don't
worry about it i'll just wait a little
bit until you'll finish explaining um i
was actually just at the bitcoin
conference which was amazing by the way
so many interesting speakers um and
there was some very fascinating
announcement one particular um
announcement actually caught my eye it
was the news that strike is partnering
with ncr and shopify
so
what do you think this means for the
crypto market i've seen a lot of people
say that
uh sorry i lost you again there your
stream is a bit patchy um i think
overall
this is all great um using bitcoin as a
payment rail now whether it's was you
know
i don't think it massively helps the
bitcoin network because the use of
slots on the blockchain is relatively
limited and how um lightning works but
it allows it to use um to create faster
payment rails for certain things because
let's face it most people the purpose of
bitcoin is not to buy your goods or
certainly not now maybe in 20 or 30
years time the purpose of bitcoin right
now is to hold it um and you know as a
store of value and the last thing you
want to do is is buy something um
you know some everyday grocery on it
because
it doesn't make sense because the
expected future return is so high
so
but using blockchain rails and and
bitcoin rails to power a payment system
i think is great and it's a fantastic
development and the work that uh jack is
doing and all of this is fantastic news
but i don't think it's it's
it only at the margin drives active
addresses or value exchange which are
the two things that drive the value of
of bitcoin itself
and i know you're bullish on ethereum
and really just the um you know web 3
the metaverse the crypto industry sort
of as a whole and if you don't think
people are gonna want to spend their
bitcoin um simply because you know it's
bitcoin it's gold 2.0
how do you see the future of payments
then what are people going to be
transacting and do you think we really
will come off the dollar and be
transacting on some form of
cryptocurrency
well
the entire web 3 world currently
transacts on um ethereum everything's
priced in ethereum everything in the
metaverse is priced in ethereum
does that mean that that stays that way
who the hell knows you know i'm no
ethereum maximalist i don't know but
right now that's where it is you know
every nft is basically pricing ethereum
some are now being priced in solana so
we don't really know i don't think the
dollar goes away for a long long time um
you know that the dollar is so deeply
entrenched it is the largest network of
anything on earth pretty much and that's
hard to get rid of
but at the margin does crypto take over
more of the payment system in this
digital world for sure and different
things i think you know i think one of
the best examples of the use of bitcoin
for example has been what uh terra has
done using it as collateral i always
said it's fantastic collateral it's
actually not great for payments um yes
um you know the lightning network can
solve different things of that but
really is collateral it's fantastic and
that's what terra have done it's a great
idea and that we will see more of that
this is only the start of i think people
using
bitcoin as the collateral layer also
we'll see
as opposed to central banks using it
we'll definitely see sovereign wealth
funds um owning bitcoin because it's a
long duration
savings asset so it works perfectly for
them so
those i think are the bigger
developments that will develop for the
bitcoin ecosystem over time
um in terms of payments
we don't really know yet stable coins i
think are still in their infancy so
that's the dollar winning out still
because stable coins are dollars but for
a pure web three worlds we've seen that
is currently
uh the king of that
so the internet is pretty rough i just
caught the last bit of what you were
saying um in terms of being you know the
the main driver of that web 3 world um
but i'm still interested in i'm still
interested in you know the growth of the
lightning network um and whether you
think there's any possibility that
just because it is growing so much and
we are seeing what's happening with
strike
we could start to see um ethereum
perhaps be made redundant in some in
some way do you think that's just an
absolute impossibility it's what i hear
from bitcoin maxis quite a lot
they're just different things i i just
don't know i mean we don't care
if i'm sending you a pound or a dollar
we don't care what network it goes on
whether it goes on some ethereum layer 2
or a bitcoin layer 2
we don't really care
so i think we'll be sending money
whatever money
over all sorts of different networks and
the more interoperable this world gets
the more we don't care you just want
your money sent to you immediately
um so we're not you know stripes not
really about sending bitcoin around it's
about sending dollars using blockchain
rails so it's much quicker dollars or
euros or pounds same as bottle pay do as
well um that's now owned by um
nydig so
i think that's good and i don't think
there's it's not competition amongst
blockchains i think
different people can offer different
solutions it's essentially creating a
you know
like a stable coin element of being able
to move money around fast and that's
great
i definitely agree with you um i
generally take a maxi position other
than um being a freedom maxi but that's
another conversation um so what would
you say
it is then because this sounds so
obvious but what would you say
if people don't un
um
and solana what are they missing
what are they missing when it comes to
ethan solana
they're they're confusing
what bitcoin is
and trying to impose that onto something
else
it's like saying well
the dog doesn't look like a cat and it
doesn't purr therefore it's a useless
cat yeah well it's a dog
it's as simple as that ethereum is just
not the store of valley now ethereum
maxis will say well you know it's going
to be this ultra hard currency i don't
really care big point is a better
solution for that because of its
um further decentralization
and security of the network so it does a
perfect job ethereum is not trying to be
that ethereum is trying to be the open
internet you know the the web three the
the the new layer so again i think they
interact together and i think bitcoin is
this collateral base layer
right now it's not being used as
collateral and ethic is being uh is
being used as collateral but ether has
been used as a lot of collateral for all
of d5
um and eth staking does that
um
but that's what and solana is just a
faster cheaper version of ethereum and
it's less
uh it's less decentralized
so
that's a trade-off and that's okay too
and i don't go oh my god solana why
should that exist it's ridiculous it
exists because people want cheaper and
faster and
and they they don't care about the
maximum decentralization bitcoin people
care about the maximum decentralization
monero people care about
about the um privacy
they're all different use cases
they're all just different technologies
for different things and and that's okay
i just don't see why there's an argument
over well why can't b well ethereum's
not bitcoin no it was never supposed to
be
yeah that's the thing i always say you
know
you said people dislike the fact that um
by ethereum max is just being promoted
as this hard money decentralized you
know truly decentralized hard money
store of value um so i guess maybe
perhaps that's sort of where the the
tribalism comes in i'm not sure um but i
do have a couple of things anybody who's
extreme in any point of view is always
going to rile somebody else up
you won't roll somebody else up if you
just say look you know we can all
coexist and they're all fine and
everybody's got a good use case and and
the market will decide in the end i mean
that's it that's all there is to it
it's true the market does decide because
ultimately i think you know when it
comes to mass adoption people will
prefer um
people will prefer convenience over
everything else right so you know how
how cheap is this and how fast is this i
don't care i'm not i i do care how
decentralized it is but others may not
care how decentralized yeah but if
you're a
sovereign wealth fund who needs to store
you know 20 billion dollars of bitcoin
or of of of an asset then you're gonna
prefer bitcoin maybe
because of how much
security you've got versus other
networks you might take eth as well
because it's pretty decentralized you
know in the in the realm of
decentralization it's very decentralized
and it has a yield coming soon so you
know i can see those two assets being
on balance sheets but bitcoin is more
likely to just by the nature of what it
is
yeah i want to move on actually just a
little bit to the idea of tokenization
because i know you're pretty bullish on
it um
they have exploded tokens and nfts have
exploded over the last year um things
seem to have calmed down a little bit um
the floor price of my nft for example
has totally just dropped i didn't sell
at the right time i'm terrible at
selling um so i'd love to get your
opinion then what is the future of nft's
like what is their place in the world um
specifically though because you know how
we look at bitcoin and we go yeah that's
the sort of value ethereum yep you're
the internet specifically
specifically nft is the ability to have
any contract unique contract
exchangeable storable and recordable
every single contract
that is a concert ticket that is a
contract for you to turn up and the band
to play that will go on nfts it is the
contract between you and an artist i
want to hold your art and i want the
rights to your art that is a contract
it will be for insurance contracts we've
seen it in defy nfts are the massive
enabler to attach digital things onto a
blockchain and exchange the value
now what nfts don't do is scale because
they're unique by nature non-fungible
tokens and that's why social tokens come
in because these are the
fungible elements
of the same thing so let's say you're a
giant pop star you issue a bunch of nfts
they could be music rights they could be
photographs they could be concert
tickets there could be all sorts of
things
but you might have a social token which
is the system of money within your
network
and so that's really where this is going
and nfts have very specific use cases
and we're just seeing the beginning of
it
so annoyingly i missed the last bit of
what you just said can you just go back
a little bit i'm so sorry about the
sexual token
yeah so so
social tokens are the currency for these
large communities
so we've seen board yacht club is a
bunch of nfts yuga labs bunch of nfts
crypto punks board 8 yacht club me bits
but they've just launched the social
token which is now allows it to scale
amongst a much larger community it
becomes the operating system of money
for that community
so um
that is really important that nfts
themselves are the core assets
within that community and again it can
be a contract or it can be an asset
itself these are really big concepts and
um you know i think people should listen
to my interview with punk 6529 that i
did on real vision crypto which is free
so just get a real vision crypto.com
it's a two and a half hour interview
with probably well easily the best
thinker in the entire space and what
this actually means and why it's so
important that we will not have a
decentralized web 3 future without nfts
being mass adoption same with social
tokens that has to happen
what is the value though in somebody
like me for example buying a form of
social token a celebrities token what is
the direct value what do i gain from it
well it depends whether the celebrity
and the community drive you value itself
so it's about the utility of that token
and what you get from it so if you get
let's say
it's a big celebrity there's a big
network it's vibrant and you get
first rights for concert tickets you
know things that always sell out you get
first right to merchandise you get to
connect to other fans you get rights to
have meet and greets you get the ability
to be able to invest in the ip of songs
you get all these benefits from being
part of the community much like you live
in the uk
that your social token is the british
pound that gives you a right to operate
within the british system you can shop
within a store there you can't shop with
dollars or euros you have you know
this is what currencies do they enable
the system that you live in to operate
yeah i see this absolutely happening um
it's just going to be one of those slow
growths and one thing which really
caught my eye is um
you tweeted to elon musk suggesting that
twitter implement a token system a bit
like reddit so the first red flag there
for me
was what about the sec isn't that going
to be security how do how would we even
make that happen from a regulatory
standpoint if you give it away it's not
a security
what do you mean give it away
you airdrop it to the users okay
according to use
so if you are a heavy user you get given
tokens
if you are beneficial to the network you
get given tokens
so then what happens is you get given
tokens exactly as the ape token did and
then it establishes a price
so you have not sold anything to anybody
therefore it is not a security
and why would you
and why would you not just have what we
currently have use one of the assets
that we have whether it's ethereum
whether it's doge whether it's bitcoin
why would we have to create something
new
because it it is therefore specifically
used for that community
and so what you're doing is you can
create some form of walled garden ways
you say if you operate within this
community
you earn this now if you're in the uk
and your employer says well i don't pay
you in any currency you can't pay your
taxes you can't go to the supermarket
you know because you've got yen in your
bank account don't work
now can you use bitcoin for
incentivisational money
of course
but you get more flexibility if you've
got your own currency which is why all
governments have their own currencies as
opposed to adopting a single currency
in europe we've got a single currency
but amongst a bunch of nations and we
you know we will see similar
interactions between different
communities
but it means that the therefore the
platform is able to issue because if
they use bitcoin
who pays for that bitcoin if i'm going
to air drop it to lair for being a great
participant on twitter i now have to go
and buy bitcoin and give it to you
but if i create my own token it doesn't
cost me anything
you can accumulate tokens and we can
create an ecosystem that you can
exchange these tokens so all these
people who came at me on twitter say
well you should just use the lightning
network i'm like you're missing the
point
it's who's going to pay to give the 300
million twitter users money
i'm sorry it doesn't work that way
what it is is a behavioral incentive
reward system that you build value from
and if you don't it shows the network's
not good and you've not created value
or utility and you should be able to
earn them by let's say you tweet a lot
you get high engagement even you don't
have to be the biggest user but your
engagement's high therefore maybe you
should be given more tokens and those
tokens maybe allow you to spend it on
something else within the platform or
use it for advertising promotion of your
own network or whatever it is and so
then maybe goods and services can be
transacted on twitter for those tokens
and then what will happen is the
automatic market makers will allow you
to take those tokens off and exchange
them for pounds dollars bitcoin eth
whatever you want
and if too much money leaves the
ecosystem it's telling you you're not
adding enough value to the ecosystem so
the network's not good it's as simple as
that you sell stuff that's not useful
you keep stuff that's useful
yeah so it's all about essentially
maintaining a very healthy ecosystem
i can see that
because if you don't the value goes down
which is the genius behind all of these
things is if you destroy your network
by uh destroying your community or the
value of that community your token goes
down
so it it incentivizes the community to
create a vibe a vibrant ecosystem
so what do you think about the idea of a
currency of the internet
having one currency that we use all over
the world and we don't have any of those
annoying cross-border payments and
things like that just one crypto
why do you need to
it just sounds more convenient rather
than having to go in and out of
different ways
i can switch my
i can switch
i can make your bitcoin payment from my
eat swap it instantaneously at zero cost
it kind of doesn't matter it's the old
fiat world where if i'm switching from
cayman islands dollars to pounds because
i need to send you 50 quid
it's a nightmare takes three days costs
a fortune but this new world that's gone
away
now
will one currency be larger than others
over time probably
which one will it be i've no idea but
stable coins have actually made the
dollar very useful because now i can
send you a stable coin in seconds
yeah so
you know again people are just always
looking at it through one lens without
saying what are you trying to solve
we're trying to solve instant payment
system for starters well stablecoin sold
that really well now if the answer is
well i don't want fears well fine then
you've got the choice you can have you
know bitcoin you can have ethereum you
can have solana whatever you want it
depends whether the other person accepts
it and if they don't then you've got an
automated market maker like uniswap
he'll automatically swap it into a
different currency for you
instantaneously at almost no cost so it
kind of works pretty well
i would have loved to have seen you
debate someone at the bitcoin conference
um
i you know i don't
it's difficult to debate people who
don't want to who don't want to open
their minds
to the fact that you can be liberal in
your opinions and you can change them
over time as things change
and there's nothing wrong with thinking
that bitcoin
is the only solution for you
absolutely fine
why do i care
and
but they seem to care if anybody else
doesn't think that and that's holds true
of any maximus of anything
same in religions it doesn't make sense
you know basically we all go to a bar we
socialize with each other we shouldn't
care what religion you're in what crypto
you're in but for some reason it seems
to matter
so much to people
um and i get it they want to be
proponents for their own network and
they want their network to survive i get
that and that is a good part of the
space but it doesn't have to be
one thing
fits all
yeah i mean i just think from
conversations that i had the mentality
is they think everything else is
dangerous and a scam
well anything else attention is
essentially um i don't know if you can
hear me i think it's frozen um giving
giving it giving anything else attention
is essentially um is essentially taking
them away from the best type of money
which would allow society and humanity
to flourish
that is their opinion and they're
entitled to that opinion
but you can't force somebody to have
your opinion if not you're doing what
the missionaries did which was go and go
into countries and force people to take
a religion on by coercion that's not the
way
the way should be by proving
allowing bitcoin to flourish and prove
that it is better over time
but that is not the way it goes
and this idea that everything's a scam
so one of the
one of the things that the bitcoin has
held was in a bear market
bitcoin is the only one that survives
and everything else goes to zero
since the bear market ethan's
outperformed
and i'm not saying that as an ethmax i'm
not i don't give a [ __ ] what currency
what works over time i literally don't
care um
i would care for the whole space that's
what i care about i really care about
this whole space
um but the point is ethel performed so
it's like huh
that's not the narrative
the narrative is they all get exposed in
a bear market it's all narrative and
it's not true
it's just simply not true
is bitcoin what is true is bitcoin the
most decentralized strongest most robust
network
yes true
is it the only answer to everything
absolutely categorically no
which leads me on my next topic actually
um i want to get into web 3 because
you've probably said that um web 3
bitcoin and ethel will change every
business model i really want to
understand how and what that means for
content creators like me because i you
know i'm putting the
interview out
on and put interview out on youtube so
will i have to migrate to a different
platform will there be just one platform
what does it mean
i think that all platforms will adopt it
and i've spoken to a lot of people at
youtube and i've spoken to a lot of
people at meta and all of this i think
they understand where this is going
and i think that they understand that
leia needs to be in charge of our own
audience and therefore doesn't need a
third party advertiser you may choose to
but
you also don't want your eyeballs
necessarily
monetized without sharing some of the
economics of that which you do somewhat
but not a lot of
and the ability for you to be
rewarding fans with tokens
and digital assets for your super fans
and be able to engage with them on these
platforms is going to drive the land
network bigger and more vibrant so now
you're working directly for your fans
right now all you get is engagement
so you look at your twitter numbers you
look at youtube numbers that's all
you're getting and in exchange you're
getting a share of the ad revenue from
google
nothing from twitter
and you're getting um
sponsorship revenue because you've got
reach
but if you're in charge of your own
sovereign state of liar and you you do
it that way where you've got your own
system of tokens nfts
you give people access to you so you can
have you know 100 people on a zoom call
together and they get to talk to you
once every month and
given different layers of access
that becomes web 3 where the community
owns a share of their community so
they're working with the influencer
right now
i watch you on youtube
i'm being served ads for the privilege
of watching it why should that be
now again ads aren't inherently evil
what's evil is the fact that
we're all getting monetized and nobody's
getting a share of it or a significant
share in it
and we can change that via web three
where
where communities participate in the
networks much like in bitcoin you hold a
bitcoin and you're now a network
participant and you're incentivized to
grow the network which is why people get
very passionate about it
well if your fans
were
interested in growing your network and
they wanted and they were going to get
financial benefit from doing so
well that digital marketing explodes it
changes everything
so this is why it's going to change
every business model because
if you think about a fashion brand
nike
or adidas or anybody
they
pay so much in marketing costs they're
paying to google they're paying to
facebook they're paying in newspapers
they're paying to billboards they're
paying to conferences they're paying
paying paying
now if you tokenize that community
you can get rid of all of that layer of
costs
and get your audience or your community
members to promote your products for you
because they're going to be
incentivizing on tick tock and make
videos about them or make youtube
content or tweets about it because the
more people who buy the product and come
into the network the more valuable the
network becomes because the network gets
a share of it so let's say you're a
music fan and you buy a token in
rihanna's new
album and you buy the
fractionalized part of one song the ip
for the first three months
so you're now going to go on tick tock
all day
and try and promote that one song
if that song becomes a hit you'll make a
money from it
so
that sports that the pop star now does
not have to pay for marketing she's not
paying google and facebook they're not
doing anything the the members are doing
it because they're incentivized to do it
much like everybody in the bitcoin
network is incentivized to get people on
board into bitcoin because the value of
bitcoin goes up
fast
donating
um i understand
again it's about creating that economy
and that i'm saying i understand it's
really interesting it's about creating
that economy and that ecosystem um
that's going to take some time to get to
i think um but what i don't understand
is like how it looks practically because
i keep you know i think it'll take some
time to get to
i don't think so
all of this space is moving much faster
than you can ever possibly imagine
so i'm working on this space a lot of
people are this is what nfts are nfc is
exploded onto the screen
you know onto the scene right they're
coming so fast this space is growing the
crypto space overall is growing at 137 a
year and the internet back at roughly
the same stage was growing at 65 a year
it is twice the speed i see this many
times people that understand what i'm
talking about twice the speed of the
internet in terms of adoption so if it's
growing 137 a year now we're at 300
million users we're at six or seven
hundred million users this time next
year we're at one and a half billion
users the year after
now that will happen
at scale because of what these giant
communities are going to do
the giant communities being fashion
brands music sports
um
film franchises tv all of this they're
all coming into these new business
models
so on a practical standpoint though
how's it going to look because i keep
hearing people say um you know you it's
really you own your
it's really simple on here
you will get paid
into your wallet for participating in
the communities that you belong to
so maybe there's a beauty brand you're
involved in that you really like that
you think is really cool and maybe
there's a a bunch of influencers you're
involved in some music and bitcoin right
so maybe those are your cultural things
and maybe a fashion brand that you love
as well right and you're part of the
community you're helping promote it
you're doing stuff you want to be
involved you have the tokens on your
phone and these are like universal basic
equity because you're earning them by
being a
a person in the network who's doing good
for the community and so you've got a
bunch of these things that are valuable
that you've not had to pay for in many
circumstances
you may want to buy more because you
really believe in it
but you may get awarded them so you're
getting free money
for being a good community member
and helping drive those networks and
they'll all be on your mobile phone and
then you will be able to spend them
either within that network or exchange
them outside of that network for other
things
so it's a world of having multiple
currencies for multiple things like when
you go on holiday to spain you have to
use
euros and if you go on holiday to
australia you need aussie dollars so you
are leaving one community going to
another and you use their currency it's
the same
but we're going down to smaller
currencies
but in terms of platforms are we saying
like twitter's still going to exist will
youtube exist or will there just be one
platform no it'll be across everywhere
now does it mean that
meta screw it up and get it wrong
and people leave
possibly
do twitter adopt this fast enough who
knows
it's bloody hard to build a new twitter
because there's 300 million people using
all day
so
the most likely outcome is twitter say
we're going to integrate this world
which is why i tweeted elon musk because
this is where they're going to have to
go if they want hyper engagement if they
don't want to sell ads and they want to
create a reward system that makes
twitter a better place because therefore
if you're a bad network participant
then the value of the network goes down
so it stops people destroying networks
so
it's going to be across all platforms
you won't even notice it
it'll just be part of what you do much
like you go into this financial world
and suddenly you own shares and all of
these things
now they're on different stock exchanges
you can use different brokerages they
already care you've got to share an
apple you've got sharing you know
facebook whatever it is
so it's it's that world it's a
multi-asset world that operates across
different chains
that are
and we can transfer the assets from one
to the other
back it cut out a little bit but i i got
what you said um this internet is not
good i need to get this sorted um yeah
no i think i think it's been really
fascinating um i want to just move on a
little bit um and talk about um more to
do with regulation um we're sort of not
really sure what's going on right now i
know that you're a big advocate for
mass adoption only being able to happen
with regulation um sort of a regulation
being inevitable um so how is this all
going to move forward with um regulation
and you know sec we sort of touched on
that they've made it really clear and i
said this ages ago gary genzer came out
all guns blazing and said we want to ban
everything everything's terrible
that is classic negotiation tactics you
start with the hardest line first and
you try and negotiate to the center and
you try and keep it a bit on your side
so he tried to go in hard he hasn't even
got the mandate the cftc haven't got the
mandate nobody's got the mandate yet so
they're trying to do this um this
cross-governmental
um
um policy committee to do this
but what they've said is yeah we get it
it's real it's happening and we have to
work with it
so it's exactly playing out as i said it
would is they will reach a decent
compromise they will have to rewrite
some laws like the securities laws and
the howie test over time because they'll
realize it's not going to work and if
the u.s wants to be a world leader they
have to change that europe doesn't have
a howie test europe has other issues
however you know and so people are going
to figure this out over time and the uk
made a great statement of what they're
trying to do they've said yep we get it
web 3 is coming
stable coins are part of the economy we
think they're good uh we understand that
that the world is changing and we're
going to allow this to happen and we'll
have a like light touch regulation best
we can and we're going to be adaptive so
we know the space is moving so there's
no point trying to regulate it with an
iron fist now let's see how it goes
everyone's going to do that
it's too big you can't have it you know
as i said by next year there's 700
million people using this what are you
going to do just suddenly say no it's
just not going to happen so all it is is
them being comfortable that they get
their share of taxes
yes and the
shenanigans aren't going on that's all
it is
and we make it you know everyone's you
know shaking their fists screaming at
each other but that's all they really
care about is please don't destroy our
own system of money
uh try not to hide money from bad things
and that's basically it
and then we continue as normal i totally
agree yeah and this space just keeps
growing
super fast because because they accept
it
you mentioned stable coins um and i
actually want to ask you about that
where do you see stable coins playing
out um
in in the global
there we go we're back sorry
what can i do
right
my question was cbdc's versus stable
coins
the uk has made it clear and i think the
fed has made it pretty clear they're
both going to probably coincide
and operate with each other
what i think seems to be moving towards
is the central banks will have their own
version so let's say they want to have
hand out stimulus you can give it
directly to people's wallets
maybe
and maybe the government has a wallet of
which you pay your taxes from or
whatever
but you'll have private wallets private
cbd
private stable coins i think they're
accepting that technology moves too fast
to not use existing rails that the
private sector has built i think they're
all going to come to that solution
singapore got to that solution too i
think india's coming to that solution
that they're gonna have to use
all sorts of different
uh existing blockchain rails now what
blockchains they're built on who knows
nobody cares um you know they will just
be built on different things and you
know people hate it but a bunch of stuff
will get built on you know xrp a bunch
of stuff will get built on on some layer
of eats some will get built on you know
cosmos nobody cares as long as i can
send you the dollar
well i'm going to leave it there because
the wi-fi is too tough um but i want to
thank you so much it's been such a
pleasure um it's always really
fascinating to talk about um web3 in the
metaverse because that's something that
i i know is inevitable but i struggle to
fully um you know understand um so i
really appreciate you taking the time
and also just dealing with the wi-fi
it's been a bit hectic
not at all not at all i hope i didn't
rile too many people up by being wildly
liberal um in uh in the space but you
know
just
it's an exciting place and we just let
it develop as it develops
yeah absolutely hopefully i'll catch up
with you again um when the wi-fi is a
little bit better because i still have a
few more questions but i'll leave with
that for now i want to thank you so much
for coming on and thank you everyone for
joining we'll see you next time take
care thanks
[Music]